you want to have a very clear vision of
what your future is going to look like a
lot of people say Robin where do I start
I want to start a new business I want to
become a better artist I want to find
the love of my life where do I start you
just start your days are your life and
miniature all you need to do is not
worry about the next week the next month
the next year forget about that that's a
waste of time
own your day need motivation watch a top
10 with believe nation what's that
believe nation it's Evan my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have Michael Jordan level talent at
something and I want you to find it
embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's get your motivation
to attend and get you believing in you
grab a snack on chewing today's lessons
from a man who went from being a
litigation lawyer up until the age of 25
to now becoming a best-selling author
trainer and motivational speaker he's
Robin Sharma and here's my take on his
top ten or so success volume 4 enjoy
also if you want to know what Robin
Sharma and a bunch of other thought
leaders think about building confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series
where every day for the next 254 days
for free you will get a 30 second to
five-minute video to help you build
unstoppable confidence check out the
link in the description below one of the
real reasons we don't do the things that
frighten us is because we are afraid of
being judged we are afraid of failure we
are afraid of success we are afraid of
stumbling what I'm suggesting to you is
one of the reasons we don't really step
into our heroic nature as human beings
is because we're attached to the outcome
and so to become fearless why not find
some time every day to practice becoming
fearless why not use whatever irritates
you or frustrates you or frightens you
during your day as bravery training and
so stop resisting I encourage you stop
resisting the natural flow of epic
performance
stop resisting the natural seasons of
life
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one my personal favorite lead dye lead
thyself I can't say it I rather take it
off with rule number one my personal
favorite lead thyself I'm gonna get
right into the first rule which is
leader lead thyself so leadership is not
just for CEOs whose leadership is not
just for prime ministers and presidents
and people with large bank accounts and
massive offices leadership is not only
an opportunity but the responsibility of
every man woman and child on the planet
today no matter what it is you do
whether you're a filmmaker a startup
entrepreneur a manager of a corporation
a bread creator or whatever it's got
Baker I guess there'll be a baker
whether you're a teacher whether you're
a firefighter whether you're a
politician whether you are a gardener
whether you are a wall maker I don't
know whatever it is you do but every day
you walk out in the world gives you not
only that opportunity but brings with it
the awesome responsibility to show up as
a leader because leadership really isn't
a title you know my book the leader I
had no title you've probably read it
leadership is less about a title and
it's more about an approach a way of
being and some of the traits of leaders
without titles the radiant optimists in
a world gone cynical one of the things
about leaders without titles they don't
see their job as a job they see their
job as a craft no matter what their work
is they understand there's dignity in
all labor one of the traits of leaders
without titles they are relentlessly
improving everything they touch so they
leave it better than they found it and
so the first rule for a monumental life
is simply leader lead thyself which just
means see yourself as a leader and don't
wait for the people around you to start
leading lead where you're planting
lead by example you stand up first be an
army of one when it comes to leadership
and spreading that leadership
possibility around you rule number two
have clarity clarity is the DNA of
mastery so if you look at the Titans of
business the true leaders in finance
these people literally will say look at
my charts they if you look at a great
military leader you look at a great
athlete
they have such granular in a world of
superficiality they have shifted to
massive granularity so they know in
intimate detail exactly what their
future timeline will look like
why because clarity breeds and builds
and is the DNA of mastery you want to
have a very clear vision of what your
future is going to look like and when
you know in intimate detail what your
future will look like then you
automatically subconsciously as well as
consciously can say no to the important
so you say a giant yes to the few things
that are most important you've heard me
share this before Confucius said it so
well first the person who chases two
rabbits catches neither
and so what I'm encouraging you to do is
this exercise before you go to sleep
tonight let's make this very tactical I
call it the 100-year timeline on a
single page a single page from where you
now are 100 years out into your ideal
future I want you every single milestone
on a single line to say here's where I
now am
here's what's gonna happen next week
next month next quarter next year three
years five years ten years 25 years 50
years 75 years 1 year 100 years until
you have a 100 year timeline on the
other side of the piece of paper with
crayons so you tap into your part of the
brain responsible for creativity or
right brain okay with crayons draw out
your ideal family life draw up one year
away draw out your business life one
year away draw out your adventure life
one year out into the future draw out
your financial life draw out your
material life literally on a page with
crayons so you're not thinking because
here's a I think a needle moving insight
world-class comes from instinct versus
intelligence you get your best ideas
when you get out of your thinking and
just to give you some neuroscience the
seed of reasoning is the prefrontal
cortex but there's a phenomenon I teach
in my live events called transient
hypofrontality this is the secret of
genius geniuses don't get their ideas
for uber Amazon the electric bulb Tesla
Shakespeare the polio vaccination SpaceX
great ideas don't come from the
intellect the-- they don't come from the
neocortex reasoning and thinking all
great heroes and great inventors and
great creators dialed in to something
deeper when you get out of your
neocortex through solitude and my life
structure that I teach called the tight
bubble of total focus and when you get
away from distraction and you immerse
yourself in deep creativity and creation
and you find your laboratory or what I
call your Menlo Park like Edison it is
Menlo Park which was with the wilderness
away from the world what happens the
prefrontal cortex it's silent and it's
called transient transient which means
temporary transient hypo small
frontality the neocortex the seat in
your brain of thinking actually shuts
down for a short period of time this is
profound information and will confirm
your brain is built for genius but if
you don't do the right things you're not
going to be able to allow the genius to
see the light of day rule number three
master your inner self you might have a
great mindset positive thinking but if
you have a heart set full of anger if
your emotional life is sad if you're
disappointed from the
if you haven't done that the sweat
lodges and the journaling and the body
work and the affirmations to really open
up a heart set then you can have the
mindset a little Elon Musk you can have
the mindset of a Steve Jobs you can have
a mindset of a Kobe but you're gonna
sabotage yourself from world class and
to me this is the great myth of positive
thinking you see a lot of people they
read all books they're positive thinkers
they've got the vision boards nothing
changes why because subconsciously
there's this wounding and a lack of
deserve ability and it's unconscious and
so they haven't done the worker you may
have not done the work to make the
wounds of underserved ability and
scarcity and the low self-worth
that's why positive thinking alone does
not work this is to me a revolutionary
insight and by the way a lot of the
people who teach positive thinking in
the past our men so it's very male mind
and a lot of the people who are pioneers
of heart said are women heart empathy
healing and so self mastery to me and
this is a pioneering model that I teach
at personal mastery Academy it's not
just mindset that's only 25% of self
mastery and as you know self mastery is
the DNA of outer mastery you're never
going to perform higher than what's
going on within mindset is only 25%
heart set your emotional life working
from confidence and love and service and
that sense of internal freedom is only
another 25% that so those two are only
50% there's a third interior Empire you
want to get to world class which is
health set working on your energy your
nutrition your daily exercise hacking
your longevity eating the right
supplements getting a massage every to
which you know my to massage protocol
doing your 60 minute nature walk every
week
so that your health set is at
world-class but that's only 75% of the
equation towards self mastery you have a
great mindset great heart set great
health set but if you haven't worked on
your soul set turning down your ego you
know you know what disease and what
energy depletion is caused by your ego
beating you relentlessly about you not
being enough and seeing your industry
peers succeeding and you feel insecure
and irritated and angry and jealous well
where do you do that work within your
soul set the forth into your empire and
as you do that you turn down the ego and
you open up your humanity and you open
up your spiritual life and you become
more soulful and then you release work
that is artistry versus just to win in
the next few months when you literally
give your life over to a mighty mission
that is larger than your ego and you
literally start to see your work as a
ministry for the benefit of humanity and
if you literally if you're an artist or
an entrepreneur or CEO manager or coder
a doctor a fighter firefighter but
literally if you saw your work as your
poetry and your artistry and you were on
a mighty mission that was larger than
even your your ego and yourself what
would the caliber of your output be rule
number four - vine own self be true rule
number four to thine own self be true
you're gonna say Robin that sounds sort
of familiar of course a Shakespeare to
thine own self be true you know Oscar
Wilde said it's so much more elegantly
than I ever could he said be yourself
everyone else is taken you know Jack
Welsh when he was at General Electric
one of our clients GE he said never lose
yourself on the way to the top wow what
amazing advice for you and me never lose
yourself on the way to the top to them
to thine own self be true never betray
your authenticity never lose your boots
on the ground
and so to thine self be true means as
you make your rise to legendary don't
forget what makes you great hardwork
humility
serving your customers working on your
craft playing the long game
understanding the genius takes decades
versus good genetics rule number five
just start the bow to tightly strung is
easily broken says one of the Proverbs
balance is a gorgeous thing so be
monomaniacal in your execution around
your high-value targets your HV tease
your mission plan but also build in some
rewards and that's going to send a
gorgeous message to your conscious and
your subconscious mind that hey this
daily practice of execution around my
deliverables is a beautiful thing and
you create this thing called momentum
and the monk who sold his Ferrari how
about back and I saw this recently I
think there's a whole chapter on
momentum and you become like this I love
skiing you start off small but as you go
down the slope you pick up momentum a
lot of people say Robin where do I start
I want to start a new business I want to
become a better artist I want to find
the love of my life I want to be a
world-class creative I want to multiply
my financial life where do I start you
just start you just start there's great
power in the start and when you start
life starts supporting you rule number
six master the skill of communication
most leaders most business people most
entrepreneurs most human beings have
never learned to be masterful
communicators and the very nature of
influence and impact which is the
leaders job is communication I mean in
school where you given a communication
course very few people have been taught
that in your personal relationships have
you read books on communication well
that leads to I mean in in an intimate
relationship or even just with a friend
it's the little miscommunications that
overtime stack into loss in your
intimate relationships it's the little
conversations that you could have had in
five minutes if you have the tools to
communicate and the awareness to speak
so literally you could release the anger
and build understanding and speak out
your needs and feel the need to be heard
all those little things if you had
learned how to do that over and done it
in five minutes with your intimate
partner you might not have lost the
relationship and in your professional
life learning to communicate inspires
your teammates you know if you look at
the great leaders of humanity the Nelson
Mandela's the mother theresa's the
Martin Luther King Junior's the john f
kennedy's if you look at the great
business builders Steve Jobs great
example right he would be on the stage
at the product launch and then that
favorite line one more thing and that's
when he would reveal the latest piece of
technology that would create industry
dominance when Steve Jobs was at Apple
well he was a masterful communicator and
Bud Tribble over at Apple called it his
reality distortion field Steve Jobs was
a master salesman he knew exactly what
to say to get people to believe in the
impossible
to allow their I can't to be less
valuable than their I can't rule number
seven serve with our customers my team
runs a protocol called at an x value
obsession how can we deliver ten times
the value at every single touch point of
the user experience that our customers
come to the live events or go into my
online course or even read my books are
expecting their they pay $20 for a book
or $30 for a book how can I give them
millions of dollars of real value
someone said to me recently in your
mastery sessions you're giving away the
store or something like that you know
like I sort of can't believe how much
value you give and my reply was because
my intent is to serve I mean this is not
a business for me yes I run a business
and a series of businesses I'm an
entrepreneur but the point really is my
intent is so much larger than that I'm
on a mission bordering on an obsession
to help everyday people understand the
neurobiology of greatness and they can
lead without a title if you've read my
book the leader had no title that they
have heroism in them and then giving
them the neuroscience the research the
performance data that will help them win
in their careers live great lives live
their potential this is so much more
than a business for me and this comes
from value number two I see this as a
movement a sense of community a sense of
giving a sense of helping you fortify
the genius within you in a very
difficult world so you say huh Robin has
giving me thousands of ideas in these
free mastery sessions that I can choose
to act on every day to go out there and
fire proof my heroism so I can do great
work that Wow's the world do great
things for my family and leave an impact
on history that stands the test of time
and if I do that in my own way that I've
served you and I've done my job well
rule number eight get great at your
craft eighth rule for a monumental life
is get great at your craft
look you have a gargantuan competitive
advantage because most people are caught
up or card-carrying members and I say
this with respect but it's reporting
reality most people in the world right
now in business are card-carrying
members of the cult of mediocrity in a
previous episode and I share this in my
leadership presentations I believe the
world today is suffering and that word
I'm choosing it consciously and
carefully from the collective deep
professionalization of business a little
while ago I was in an airport there was
a
elevator repairman and his boom box
cranking out hard rock well that's fine
but he's at work he's not at home I go
into a store these days there are people
listening to music out loud when they
should be taking care of customers you
walk into an airport and you see people
behind the desk or whatever rather than
being pros owning the game you literally
see them chit-chatting or again looking
at videos of dancing cats and people
riding bicycles off the roofs of their
houses you know what I'm talking about I
call it the collective deep
professionalization of business very few
people relatively speaking right now say
this is my craft I've got to be a pro
I've got to study the audiobooks that
relate to my game I've got a fine
Mentors I've got to read the books I've
got to practice like Federer or Serena
Williams or Muhammad Ali used to
practice you know Muhammad Ali once said
he said I hated every single one of
those early morning runs but I loved the
idea of being champion of the world rule
number nine on the day and then before
you go to sleep ask yourself this
question did I live out my plan for
today your days are your life and
miniature all you need to do is not
worry about the next week the next month
the next year forget about that that's a
waste of time own your day your days are
your life and miniature as you live each
day so you craft the rest of your life
and the day slip into weeks the weeks
become months the months become years
before you know it you've lived a
legendary life because all you did was
dial into gorgeous brilliant productive
creative loving healthy soulful days
your days are the pockets and
instruments of genius get those right
your life will take care of itself and
rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip is honor the
genius with
in you don't live your life on the
outside to fill these holes on the
inside that you haven't filled start the
interior work of self-mastery to fill
the holes so your mindset heart set
health set and soul set are full and
then you'll feel joy when you wake up
every morning and you'll work not for
the money but for the meaning and you'll
create with a fire in your belly that
will make you undefeatable it's not
because you're pursuing income is
because you're pursuing impact and craft
and love of you honoring the genius
within you do you see what I'm referring
to your outer life you still might work
hard I love working hard I love it
but I'm not doing it for the money I'm
doing it because of Who I am I have to
write I have to serve I have to use the
rest of my life
to be an instrument of impact for as
many people as possible
now I've got a really special bonus
Robin Sharma clip on how to block out
the noise but before that I want to make
sure you're moving from just watching a
video to actually taking action so I
have some homework for you the three
questions of the day for you to ask
yourself number one what is preventing
you from just getting started and how
can you overcome it question number two
what can you do tomorrow so that when
you sleep at the end of the day you can
tell yourself I owned this day and
question number three write down three
things that make you a genius honor your
greatness you can write the answers down
yourself share them with a friend or
leave them in the comments below either
way I want you moving from just
consuming another video to actually
thinking about and taking action in your
business and in your life thank you guys
so much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one where it is much
love I'll see you soon and enjoy the
bonus clip
you know you're not very smart or you
can't do that if you're a teacher and
you say you know what you can never be
an astronaut you can never be an empire
maker you're not smart enough to do this
and some teacher said that to me along
my journey you'll never you'll never
finish University and just to share the
reality I not only finished university
with a science degree but I did a law
degree and then a master's of law degree
and I only share that which is I haven't
had it easy I've been put down I have
had teachers who didn't see my potential
that's just reality you want to block
out the noise and listen to the signal
which is you're built to be a
possibility Rhian you're built to be
great
you have genius within you so calibrate
your languaging sir your words to
yourself are real class altruistic world
domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think I see
it's a bloody brief life all of you have
the potential for enormous success if
you want to know what gary vee DJ khalid
oprah and others know about empire
building that most people miss check out
the link in the description for a free
bonus video